l'habile boudy avocat bonsoir on a dit
là vous dis merci d'être avec nous on
connaissait les relations souvent
tendues entre la police et les habitants
de ces quartiers sensibles certains
habitants en tout cas est ce que cette
situation de confinement exacerbe encore
plus les tensions selon vous c'est
important de rappeler que ces violences
policières sont très résistants d'aspin
nouvelle résidence est dépeint dans cet
article particulièrement depuis une
trentaine d'années le compliment ne fait
qu'aggraver la situation
on peut le rappeler mais ce qui change
catégoriquement la donne aujourd'hui
tous les rejets numérique c'est à dire
que maintenant ces violences policières
sont beaucoup plus visibles donc existé
avant aujourd'hui à son fils mais elles
sont diffusées sur les réseaux sociaux
et dans le contexte de ce confinement
les personnes sont de plus en plus cher
donc depuis leur fenêtre elle arrive à
filmer ces scènes qui je le rappelle il
existe depuis malheureusement trop
longtemps dans le contexte de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
avec la mise en place d'une infraction
maintenant qui est le non respect finans
qui est une conservation c'est un bel
été on a vu on voit des images passées
on voit des personnes se faire contrôler
à leur portage l'union d'une attestation
d'envoi des violences qui sont légitimes
qui sont et cécile qui sont dirigés vers
une partie de la population
je pense qu'il faut pas avoir peur de le
dire aujourd'hui il faut tenir un
discours clair mais surtout un discours
de vérité
il ya une disparité donc dans la dans
les contrôles et puis dans leurs
conséquences
on se souvient cliff des images qui ont
été diffusées au début du film on ne
voyait beaucoup d les parisiens se
balader dans les abords des quais de
seine sont les jardins des tuileries et
au trocadéro toutes ces personnes là
n'étaient pas en conformité avec
non donc ce qui serait souhaitable
dans ce contexte ce serait que la
pédagogie qui est mise en place pour les
habitants des grandes villes soit aussi
la même que pour les habitants des lieux
je vous dis clairement qu'il ya plus de
contrôle dans l'est dans les quartiers
dits sensibles
clairement ce que je dis pour être
parfaitement précis je précise que la
pédagogie on met en oeuvre dans les
grandes villes doit être appliquée
également dans les quartiers centre
n'évite pas le confident de la même
manière les habitants dans les quartiers
populaires sont souvent dans des foyers
exigu avec nombreuses donc le
confinement en tant que telle est encore
plus difficile et j'ai envie de vous
dire que d'habiter par exemple québécois
dans un appartement spacieux donc le
contest nécessite en urgence que tout le
monde fasse preuve de retenue et que
l'urgence c'est bien sûr que chacun
respecte le confinement
mais s'il ya des problèmes liés à cette
contravention
elles doivent en tout cas bien même si
ce sont des violences policières à nos
confrères du canard enchaîné avait
rapporté une note du ministre de
l'intérieur
christophe castaner selon lui un seul
ont en tout cas le canard enchaîné le
respect du confinement dans les
quartiers populaires ne serait pas une
priorité
quelle est la réaction de l'avocat on
doit avoir de réflexion autour de 7
cette information a été diffusée dans
vos consoles soit que les services de
police ou en tout cas une sur
l'intérieur considère que si ces
personnes sont pas cons fils et qu'elle
est on sera clos comme 19
c'est moins grave que gore n'est pas
faisable c'est pas une récusation gelé
uniquement un commentaire sur cette
dépêche soit contenu des contextes et
des relations souvent difficiles entre
les jeunes et la police
il vaut mieux éviter des contrôlés par
la position c'est la suivante
moi je suis d'avis qu'il est nécessaire
avec il est indispensable d'agir avec
pédagogique le cadavre se confirme
si la personne ne respecte pas les
obligations liées à l'état d'urgence
donc être en possession d'une
attestation de sortie et même si elle
est manuscrite
j'attire l'attention sur ce point
jusqu'à des personnes qui ont été
violentés
alors qu'elle était en elle était en
possession d'une attestation demain à
street
rien ne l'interdît dans les textes si la
personne n'a pas d'imprimante et elle
peut recopier à la manifestation
et malgré ça on sait qu'il ya des
personnes qui ont été violentés
donc ils font appel au calme ces
violences doivent cesser
mais surtout il faut une prise de parole
de la part du ministère de l'intérieur
vous l'avez rappelé les débuts les
violences ont tourmenté dans les
quartiers notamment après que ce
confinement qui est difficile à
respecter pour certains selon vous le
couvre feu pourrait être une des
solutions pour apaiser les tensions ou
ça empirait peut-être une situation déjà
difficile
moi je suis pas certain qu'une mesure
encore plus liberticides viendra régler
le cas solution ce qu'il faut et gilles
encore le répéter c'est faire preuve de
pédagogie et là encore le choc des
consignes soient claires il ya eu une
confusion de la part du gouvernement
dans la mise en place de ce confinement
les attestations ont évolué les motifs
de sorties ont évolué et là on voit qu'à
paris c'est encore en train d'évoluer
maintenant il ya une attestation qui est
numérisé les motifs pareil on changeait
donc pour que la population accepte ce
compliment
il faut que les consignes soient claires
donc pas d'urgence
pas de couvre-feu pardon le couvre-feu
dans ses quartiers à mon avis ne va
faire qu'augmenter les tons clos il faut
le confinement soit appliquée et les
mesures de contrôle soient similaires à
celles
baj merci beaucoup à nabil abu dis
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
francs